i don't understand that
after 15 years
of service here
i have to get in the car and drive to
new york in order to talk to you that
doesn't seem right to me
that doesn't seem fair and i think
that i've earned more
than that
yeah
you're right yes i get it i get it
michael okay here's what i'm gonna do
okay
we will move some money around
and i will personally see to it that you
have your party
you have your figs
i will be in attendance it's gonna be
great
how's that
i quit
what
michael you have no idea how high i can
fly
hey
well my my my do my eyes deceive me is
that ron swanson hello leslie
hello april larry uh it's terry now okay
as luck would have it oh did you talk to
randy about the vote tell the northeast
that we need to put pressure on them or
else we're gonna be waiting for everyone
i'm tired of waiting on them okay sorry
this is a crazy day so what's up with
you you big lug nothing important just
thought you might want to have lunch
uh tomorrow i would love to it's been
too long
jj's diner 12 30. excellent see you then
okay so randy says the house is voting
tomorrow and they need us in washington
to prep oh my god really okay get us the
first flight out of here and grab the
missouri files meet me at my car
hey babe i gotta go to washington can
you pick up the kids
oh oh no ron i stood you up for lunch
you did yes
i waited for a while but it was pretty
easy to figure out what had happened
your life seemed pretty hectic
is that the rest of the story that i
stood you up
you were going to ask me something
that's why you wanted to have lunch
ron you were going i was going to ask
you for a job
in the federal government
just saying it out loud feels dirty
there's a rumor the new captain will be
here today
now i don't know who once you're sending
us
but it doesn't matter
because we're a family
we're strong and together we can do
anything
what's up ding dongs
i'm your new captain the vulture
still hot now i know we have our history
me valtteri and your cases
me telling you to eat my farts that's
all in the past cause now that i run
this precinct things are gonna get much
much
worse
so suck it
no
sorry
kevin
kevin where are you i missed my song
buddy
yeah michael i'm at garrity's you have
to come down here just pay for it and
we'll reimburse you when you get back no
i i brought my money michael there's
something that you need to see what is
it just hurry
is he okay yeah he's at the supermarket
he needs me you know the party driving
to the supermarket it's a big day for
him
yeah
that's true
don't move a muscle i will be back
momentarily all right
don't you get drink you finish your
drink and then i'll okay i'll be back
well it's good to see you it was great
[Music]
oh okay
oh
hello michael wow kevin really
we're
sorry we're in the middle of a party is
this why you called me down here yeah
michael i just uh
i i think you kids have a lot to catch
up on oh okay yeah
thanks kevin
um
okay we're back
clear the chamber please
i think i'm about to get fired ron
there's nope
unless you have any objections we'll be
ending this investigation and moving on
to the punishment phase
i have no objections
we hereby hand down the following
judgment you will be suspended for two
weeks with pay
just two weeks
correct
this concludes the investigation
i thought i was gonna get fired
i should have gotten fired why didn't i
get fired
ben asked for a private meeting with the
committee and he took full
responsibility for the bribe and
resigned effective immediately what wait
hang on you can't let him resign
i tried to talk him out of it but his
mind was made up
my job is to protect the government from
fraud and corruption
i was just doing my job
and i hope that you can understand that
i do
honestly i do because your actions
wounded me to my core which is not easy
since the bulk of my workouts are
focused on core strengthening it's
midnight so i guess i'm an amazing human
slash genius
yeah
although
you might want to read the inscription
on that their belt why
oh no what does it say
amy santiago will you marry me
surprise
i'm so confused i don't know what's
happening right now i'm so confused i
don't know what's happening right now
title your sex tape oh my god i'm
shaking i'm definitely gonna cry title
of your sex tape wait is this really
happening is this part of the heist if
this is part of the heist i will dump
you so hard no please look it's really
happening okay it's not part of the
heist i promise this is
what you are i love how beautiful you
are
i love your face and i love your butt i
should have written this down first no
no it's okay go on i love
how much you pretend to like die hard i
like the second one you don't have to
okay yeah you're
kind and you're funny and you're the
best person i know and
the best detective
also for reals i love your butt i love
yours too gross
amy santiago
will you marry me
jake peralta i will marry you so
i know we left the other day on a note
of uncertainty but after some more
thought
i'm very pleased to be able to offer you
this job
great
i'm so glad
we're all very excited you're going to
be joining us it'll be nice to have
another mba around here i'm excited too
okay
bye
who was that nobody
you and i are done what
are you sure everything will be all
right if april goes to vet school there
are no sure things in life son but you
two seem pretty solid to me change is
good i guess not to me leslie's going
around asking everybody if they're
better off than they were a year ago
all i care about is that i'm the same
if i'm the same as i was a year ago i'm
happy wait i forgot
who the hell is pregnant what i found a
pregnancy test at your cabin and i
checked with all the girls who were
there it wasn't any of them
hello darling what a surprise hey
can we talk maybe in private
[Music]
so some of us ended up adopting those
elderly dogs it's been great pepper's
been getting me out of the house going
on runs yeah my dog ruby doesn't do
anything she just lays there all day
she's so chill
what do you feed her well i put out pro
bow wow but she barely touches it she's
so dainty
is she sick how are her poops doesn't
really poop it's perfect
nothing to pick up she just kind of lies
there all day like a good girl i put on
the tv for her but i have to prop her
eyes open so she can see it
does she smell she smells horrible
it's unbelievable but i don't want to
put her in the bath
cause i'm afraid that she'll drown
people seem awful interested in you ruby
guess they're just jealous right
yeah that a girl
that a girl
and that stinks i'm gonna get this
hello jake peralta this is jimmy figgis
oh
uh
hey dog
you and ray holt took down my operation
now i'm gonna kill you both
later
dog
uh captain holt
blue skies
smiling at me
nothing but blue skies
do i see
morning greg
blue bird morning larry singing a song
nothing but bluebirds
all day long
you